そうすると小屋でも行こうかな
どういう技です僕はいう業という案に出
てるんですけども俺の専念開いているの千
年パズルがなんと発売されました
[音楽]
そんな気軽に手に入るものだったのか5
遊戯としたとても前から古代ジェットから
代々伝わる伝説のアイテムが一般的には
数字されるって言うのはどうかと思うん
ですけどもそんなことはいう因果関係ない
戦でパートでこちらビックラリー戦連発
塗っていましたはいうわぁ
見てくれ
僕だよとの僕が持ってるのはこれ千年
パズルって言うんですけどもまずそもそも
千年パズルと何なのか夕日はもう遊戯王の
アニメ別見てるんで前年 part るが
何かわかるんですけどもてっぺんパズルを
知らないと出て多いと思うんですよ兼任
パズルとは何かもともとの所有者は古代
エジプトに存在していた腹をであるこれ
ファラオの持つものなんですねそれが今回
へとビックカメラで売られていましたこれ
を入手したむとすごろくずっとそブログを
介して目という木の手に渡りいう行旧
アニメが始まったこれいう器用なはずマリ
のアイテムなんですね遊戯はこの戦連発で
つくる8年かかっている
こんな感じですねー罰月ニッパーで作って
いく月よって登ってみたいな感じだろこれ
かっこいい8吸っちゃうからまだ千年
パズルを作ってみようっと
待ってヤバイことが入ったんだけどヤバイ
こと書いてあるパズルの解き方は取扱説明
書に載せておりませんのでご注意下さい
ない1回作り方載ってないん本当に外れ
かかったらどうしよう説明書がなくて
ちょっと不安だけど僕はこの戦略パズルを
完成させるブラックマジシャン消化
持った
やばいってこれヤバイってがっちもん
じゃんこれなるほどでこれともとも
フレンド説明書乗ってるじゃんと思ったん
ですけどこれ説明書がないんでこれ e 5
を作りせて名所で個のピースを組み合わせ
て攻めパスを作るっていう要するにパープ
を作るため説明書で本当に乗ってないんだ
上地くん見てくれこれが専念パンツ類の
パーツたーーーーでまずこれを組み立てて
ビーズを作っていますこれを組み立てれば
33個になるらしいまずそれをやって
いこうと思う
泣きそうちょっとこれや第4たらもう全般
好きいいのだからめちゃくちゃかっこいい
よちょうの竹これ完成したら俺泣くはだけ
で p 席になっていきます
今1個目のパーツができたんですけども
意味がわからなすぎるこれが1個目の
ピースだよちょうの智くん
[音楽]
ああああああ
思いますポケカも ok
んだ
[音楽]
えっ
うぇい
女王
のを使って
[音楽]
今こいつっ大一番下の部分だこれページ
場所の部があっ
もうちょい
持って
うわぁ
ラストですうわあああっああこれが最後の
ピースですよし
完成しましたこれを組み立てるだけでも1
時間経ってちょっと腹買ってきたんです
けど杖道地区ここから僕は本気なイケてて
もらうよもう一人ところが作るために8人
かかったと言われているこの千年パズル僕
はさっくんでドッグtan
無振りしたただ唯一つけたのはこの一番上
の確定なんだろうなって3分でここだけ
見つかりません
[音楽]
ん
はっはまって頑張ってやってもうもうさ下
の方結構ここまで来たんですけどあれか下
のほうがしっかり作っていけばマッツァ日
気がしてきたちょっと本気出しません
んを
メッツヴィッツきてビビってきているメタ
リッ
[音楽]
ん
んえっなんかめっちゃ北岳バッハめっちゃ
mo
ん満足
ちょっと一旦休憩しますな面でたなぁ本能
はですがなんかコスプレとかしてアホ
みたいな感じでやってますけど何か見て
下さいちゃんとした立体パズルですは23
やってみてらんとなくの概要が掴めたん
ですけどその先がなかなか難しそうですね
ちょっと休憩ん
遊戯
おは学
今何もできないのか
大我くん僕はちょっと難しいかもしれない
から作るのは僕がそれからサポートして
早くいいだろう
用意スタート
崩れたロバず近くに一番近いでしょ
これはもうここができてるんですよね周り
ができないっていう
ちょっとやばいって考えた人を
[音楽]
もうやばいあーめりベビーまず振ります縁
本当にぶりいま人生で[ __ ]ブリこれ本当
に振れ本当により本当によりうーん
ああああああああ
はん
ん
[音楽]
やろうか
ています
ます
free
むりー
あった
ます
何が難しいけど平面酒津ルっておくと崩れ
ないじゃないですかこれ一体何で体花と
崩れちゃう
tee
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー
ん
[音楽]
やばい
滅びたこのフィールドロビー沼津市で行っ
ちゃったのですがいやー鉄俺萌舞子のこの
回した滅びですよ
あまたん
ん
[音楽]
終わらない配信ゆっくりしているやるだけ
一生がないぞ
そうだな
そうはならってこれ無理なんだもうまず
無理なやつ作っちゃったんじゃない
ちょっと
今日はやめよ a
仕事がちょっと1ただけさんでやっていき
ます里だからネットで見てもまだなかなか
完成まで行けてないとか多かったんでこれ
本当に難しいやつなんだろうなぁ
[音楽]
うをスライドして入ったキモ男それは
わかりたいと思うんですけどねんか
スライドして入れますね今かなり大きな
駿馬だった気がする頑張っていこうか
めっちゃなんか薄いんだけど
ってがあと5パーツじゃんこれ聞けるか
これ惜しいとこまで来てまった分ただここ
からが時服のような気もしている正直も何
が足りないかもよくわかりません
ていますすけべえまじめっちゃ制度が
できるよ絶対勝ちでもう一息っぽいです
けどそのもう一息で非常に難しい気がし
ます
[音楽]
あってまっつぼう膿盆お気を付け持つ
気持ちで part 3パートが出来まし
た目指せばせる
もう意味がわかりませんどこがどうすれば
くっつくの言葉マジでわからなくてなんだ
これまだブッカー解体しなきゃいけない
まだある気がしたんだよ
[音楽]
voodooん
ねえねえなんやねこれません
oh
もう
おかなきゃ仕事いってきます
仕事から帰ってきたぜ
を
カイバーじゃないか俺のターンみたいな
感じだっけちょっと違います
[音楽]
はいはい
もうもう見えてきた750年パズルぐらい
になってきた750年パするくらい
動きました中ですごい動きました中で
ポイントパラオが笑った
終わった方がんばらっとった
[音楽]
で惜しいところで潰れろよまじでもさぁ右
てろ
右手に全集中
からは呼吸
アヘり効能がどうか
さぁ少し前進
水が震えている
変わるかパチンという音は聞こえるかどう
かもう少しもう少し
さあ
でも全てを買ってやっと本体笑うよバーっ
眺めたパースが出た
わー
あっ上納付くんだった水に最後の一つの
ページにあった
俺はこのピースを千年パズルの真ん中に
センっ
[音楽]
time 4時間18分アニメのユニは
発明家んかかったが僕は4時間で作ったけ
って言いたいとこなんですけどもソースよ
ここがどうしても埋められなかったです
cocco がうまんないんですよごめん
だてここまで来ると崩せなくて怖くて工夫
したらでても取れないしこれにまだできる
してもないからもう本当に無理でなんです
けど正面から見るともう専念発れたんです
よユーリそれこれいればいいだけじゃんと
思うんですけどこれがおっ
いいんですよこれがどこを引っ掛けるとか
細工て順番が間違ってるとかでもなく入ん
なくなってネイルの
[音楽]
ぴょんっ
日
fam
これも
って切ってるよねー
さあこれは何はいじゃあねえっとえっと4
時間21分で完成明日んですけど絶対
おかしいんですよ明らかにパーツ月光を
待ってるんですねそんなことある結構完備
技レベルだったんですけどなぜかパーツが
入っ困ってるただ間違ってるんですけど
下達的にはまったく問題が苦戦にパズルが
できても通り沿いわかんないわかんない
わかんないけどん
ピックアッ
これでも入んないですよ
これが600本
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワン
パーツが選んだけど
close これを作ろうとしたぜうか
パラ大駄作を貸してくれません
マジでこれ
全然なんかしっかり所為か中の僕に表面に
出ないパートが終わってねそれでしっかり
固定されるようなわけです
さっきの
pou
dou
[音楽]
あった